Film Courage: Clive, you say you’re attracted
to dangerous characters, how does Walt (of
THE CONFIRMATION) fit into that?
Clive Owen: Do I say that?
Film Courage: Well….I think your IMDB says
it?
Clive Owen: (Laughs) No, I wouldn’t say
I’m attracted to dangerous characters.
I’m attracted to characters that have conflicts,
because for me, it’s always more interesting
than a character that hasn’t got conflict
and it’s more real.
So, a character that is grappling with something
is always much more interesting to play because
you’ve got more than one thing to play all
the time and this film (THE CONFIRMATION)
certainly falls into that bracket because
he’s a father, estranged from his son who
is trying to make a go of it, and trying to
do the right thing and it’s very difficult
in his circumstances and he’s got certain
demons he’s dealing with.
So it certainly falls into the bracket of
a character in conflict.Film Courage: Sure…..but
he’s redeemable?
Clive Owen: Yeah….
At the end of the day his (Walt in THE CONFIRMATION)
intentions are true and good and he’s trying
to make a go of it, but it’s not always
easy.
One thing that is very sweet about this film
is it’s about a group of characters living
in a particular area and a lot of them have
a very tough time and are struggling, but
it’s very non-judgmental.
It’s not a film that looks down on these
people.
It’s a film that you kind of have empathy
and understand how hard it is for a lot of
people.
Film Courage: Sure.
I grew up with a single parent and could relate
to a lot of the scenes in the film.
Jaeden for you, how did you prepare for your
character, Anthony?
Did you go into what his life would be like,
especially for some of the scenes like sitting
in the truck outside the bar?
Jaeden Lieberher: He (Anthony) is this good
kid.
He doesn’t usually get into trouble until
he’s with his Dad.
He’s very curious about the world and what
his father is dealing with.
I had to do the same thing.
I had to think about the different things
that was going on with my father and what
would think about during a moment where he
was in this truck all alone.
I had to think about what Anthony would be
thinking.
Film Courage: Jaeden, you are 13 now?
Jaeden Lieberher: I am 13, yes.
Film Courage: Ok…What would you recommend
to another 13-year-old on getting into the
(acting) business?
Jaeden Lieberher: Well….of course, I couldn’t
have gotten into “the business” if I didn’t
know anybody and just having this interest
in acting….
And if you don’t want to act, you don’t
necessarily have to, but it’s something
that you do, if you truly to do it.
So if you’re interested by acting and you’re
interested in being someone else, then you
should definitely pursue it.
Film Courage: (To Jaeden) And you also want
to direct one day?
Jaeden Lieberher: I would like to direct
one day.
That is why I’m so happy that I was able
to work with Bob (Nelson) and everybody else.
Film Courage: Did the two of you direct
each other at any point?
Clive Owen: Wouldn’t dream of it…..wouldn’t
dream of it (laughs).